-The rules of the game
are very simple.
I will give each of you
a password.
-Password.
-Then you are to give
a one-word clue.
That's one word only.
-How many?
-One.
-Okay.
-To get your password
to guess the password.
The team with the most points
after four words wins.
-Okay.
-Any questions?
-Well --
-Great. Let's move on.
First clue goes
to Jimmy and Kevin.
-Ooh.
-Alright.
-The password is "shrimp."
-Alright, Jimmy.
Why don't you start us off?
No cheating.
-[ British accent ] Oh, no.
[ Laughter ]
Yes, dear.
Come on. Use your words.
[ Laughter ]
-Scampi.
-Um --
Crustacean!
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, oh.
Oh, the old overthought.
[ Laughter ]
Kevin? Kevin, it's your turn.
-Holy --
-I don't know
if Tariq is gonna get this.
-Okay, let's see.
-Oh, my God!
Now I know the answer!
[ Laughter ]
-Boiled?
-Shrimp?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh! My, oh, my.
5-0.
-Are you a teacher somewhere?!
-No, let me make it very clear!
Crustacean scampi?
-A crustacean is a shrimp.
-I know.
-A crustacean --
-Classic over-thinking.
-I thought
we were doing smart --
I thought we were doing
smart answers.
-I was a little bit worried.
-Crustacean scampi?
-It just sounded too easy.
It sounded too --
-That's American TV.
Alright, next clue
goes to Tan and Tariq.
-Come on, we got this, Tan.
-The password is "Madonna."
-You are up first.
-Mm.
[ Laughter ]
-Don't over-think it.
-Virgin.
-Ooh.
[ Laughter ]
Ooh.
-Mary?
-[ Gasp ]
-No.
[ Audience oohs ]
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Vogue.
-Madonna.
[ Bell dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow!
-[ Speaking indistinctly ]
-Oh!
-Whoa! Well, the score --
-Of course the gays got --
Well, the gay got that.
[ Laughter ]
-The score is Sammy Hagar.
-Close.
-55.
Jimmy and Kevin,
next clue is for you.
-Alright.
-The password is "tuxedo."
Kevin, why don't you
start us off?
-Oh, I go first. Okay.
Um --
Formal...
-Tuxedo?
-No!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow! Wow!
Wow. Wow.
-He's such a good actor.
He'd be like, "formal."
-Wow.
-Tan would have said "attire."
-I was literally thinking
"attire."
When have you ever seen
a casual tuxedo?
[ Laughter ]
-That's true.
-Alright, final clue
goes to Tan and Tariq.
-Mm-hmm.
-Uh-huh.
-The password is "robot."
-Tan, why don't you
start us off?
-We got this, bud.
-Um -- Oh, I don't know
if this is the name
of an American show
or an English show.
-That's alright.
I watch a lot of things.
-Okay.
[ American accent ] Wars.
[ Laughter ]
[ British accent ]
If we were in England right now,
he would know.
It's not my fault
you're not British.
-Okay, wars.
Oh, gosh. Uh --
Oh, gosh.
[ English accent ] "Wohs."
-No.
-I said it in an American accent
for you. "Wars."
-[ Normal voice ] I know, but --
There's no "Wars," right?
There's no show "Wars."
-No.
-There's "Wohs."
[ English accent ] It's not
"Star Wars" 'cause it's a show.
[ Normal voice ] So I'm gonna
say, uh, is it like closet wars?
-Ooh, no.
-I don't even know
what that is. No.
-Negative.
-Okay, okay.
-I got a show --
-Okay.
R2D2.
[ Audience ohs ]
-Star?
-Oh!
-Ohh!
-Hold on. Hold on!
Hold on!
-Don't say anything.
I think I know it.
-Alright. Cool it. Cool it.
-That's alright. We got this.
-Machine.
-Robot!
[ Bell dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my goodness!
-My thanks to Tariq Trotter,
Kevin Bacon.
Tan France and I, the champions!
Steve Higgins!